you don't know that was best sign
language too
um anyway we're gonna get second video
just play it let's hear it when you're
ready
put your hand on the stove you saw
someone else put their hand on still
make it burn okay respect me back asking
you I I'll let you answer and when you
answer me no it's just it's just funny
because because like like any time you
say something that's like true or like
does it put women in the best light
right you say something that reveals
something about female nature the female
knee reaction is to always ask to
convert you so it's always who hurts you
but like if you were to if you you know
if you were to tell me your standards
say I want a guy that makes money or
whatever or guys tell her I'm never
gonna look at you and be like who hurt
you you can't make your own money [ __ ]
I'm not gonna say that I'm just like
okay that's her standards that's what
she wants but if a guy says something
along the lines up yeah I don't really
like when a girl does this [ __ ] [ __ ] or
that's some whole [ __ ] oh who hurt you
no it's I have standards too it's just
that female standards or standards male
standards are you know discrimination
cool the problem is
um thank you blessing
are men question are men allowed to have
standards
of course
um now I'm gonna ask a man I made a lot
to have standards uh not without being
judged right basically
um if you say that you prefer slim women
that go to the gym then women are going
to say you're discriminated against fat
fall beat me yeah so it's best to stay
quiet to be honest just keep your
opinions to yourself and just do you
oh no that was such a cool answer
I like that that was just like
that was just cool that's me when Kevin
Samuel said that men generally don't
want baby mamas
and fat chicks
women went crazy
but when women say they don't want short
guys
I'm broke guys everyone's yeah men get
abused
men get abused I feel sorry I feel sorry
for a short mint like if you're under
six foot
I feel sorry for you if you're burnt I
feel sorry for you I found out a crazy
stat um 80 of women have their height
filter set to what
yeah really yeah eighty percent of women
it's deep like and it's only like on
dating apps and dating apps so a lot of
girls will say my height or taller it
was only 15. 80 if y'all want a dating
dating app there's an 80 it's deep
though because like as a man like you
can't control how tall you grow do you
know what I mean but like but you can
control it
yeah but then most men won't
aesthetically pleasing women and you
can't pick the evil of course you can
you can you can make yourself look I
think you can make but if you're not
quote unquote pretty there's anything
yeah
I feel like most girls can't become like
like if you're a five six you can't
really become like an eight exactly but
but I I do think that no girl is really
gonna be below a five if she's in shape
yeah and you can be short and have a lot
of money and no one will care
I want to stop you there because you
know how much harder it is to make money
than to go to the gym and get in shape
no I'm talking about your your face I'm
talking about no but it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter because like a guy
will go for a girl that's got a dead
face here but if her body is banging
she'll bust that's true she'll fast kiss
that's true but you're saying that for a
short guy to just get rich I'm not
saying get rich I'm saying be
financially secure do you know how hard
that is just to be stable it is
difficult but it's possible yeah
it's not the same Dynamic I'm not saying
it's the same I'm never saying anything
is the same I'm saying this possible
okay the level of the playing pool is
level equal for everyone
an interesting stat if a guy is five
five how much more does he have to make
to have the same options as a guy that's
it was either five ten or six foot yeah
yeah but why do you need the same
options you don't need enough to be able
to pick the girl that you want like okay
why do you want to be like okay like
instead of attacking the question why
don't you just give me an answer what's
the question how how much more does he
have to make options as a guy that's six
are you asking me for a figure guess I
don't have a figure no I'm saying guess
I don't know okay I have to turn five to
ten thousand more what do you think
probably like 15 to 20 more than the
general person he has to make 300 000
more have the same options there's a guy
that's six foot can I just say something
what I noticed right is that most women
but me I'll say I'm a four or five
and it was like yeah 32 years because
I'm over average man because I'm an
average woman and that's what I'm saying
and he just makes me feel more than
average and I think I must be about five
five he's about five six he's at a nine
to five job for God knows however long
and I'm gonna add more more property
than him but he's got more cash than me
that's okay
this impossible it's like they want a
man that's got this man that's got that
and then when they don't and then they
look back like my man I don't fit
anybody he was always handsome
in my eyes but everybody thought that
they can they can do better
but he's like one of those slow Growers
he was always there he always had
potential and even when I earned more
than him he still gives me money
my money doesn't come into it back then
average like average women would date
average guys well now they don't like
women only swipe right on dating apps
five percent of the time so essentially
a hundred percent of women are fighting
over five percent of men on dating apps
it's the number one way people meet
today a lot of people say it's not real
but it's the number one way people are
meeting and the data is indicating we're
sharing these guys and 80 of 80 of women
put their height filter is six foot or
more
um 80 of women or no 100 of women wait
80 percent of women
women rate 80 of men is unattractive
that's what it is so it's like women
average women don't want average men but
you know what's interesting 80 of women
will rate
men to what is it oh sorry women rate 80
of Madison of men as unattractive but
those women that are doing that have
other people's hair on their head they
have makeup or they have makeup on their
face they have fake nails they have fake
eyelashes fake lips fake lips and I've
always said attacks the whole thing and
that said if you were to literally like
Kevin Kevin strip yourself back take all
the hair off your head that's not yours
take your makeup off have a shower come
out the shower let me see exactly what
you look like right let me see exactly
what you look like when you go to bed
because what it is is that a lot of
modern women think that they are eights
nines and tens and they're really fives
bro you see they're like fives and a
half it's like you've got a lot of
average average women they want access
to the one percent of men you know what
I mean and that's because of obviously
enhancements filters Etc and then you
got hella Sims just gassing you up so
you've got loads of people just feeding
into this like false sense of like
entitlement that you don't have really
because when it comes down to it the one
percent that you're going for they're
never going to take you seriously and
that comes down to the communication as
well because this is always that bad but
communication like the way in which I've
seen some women communicate with men
right that you're on the same level
don't don't communicate with that man
like you're above the level you're above
his level do you know what I mean it's
like you're communicating with that man
in a certain way because you've got
other people's hair on your head and
you've got your makeup on and you've got
your lashes on and you've got your nails
on but you wouldn't communicate with
that guy the same way if you just
stepped out of the shower with nothing
like that and a lot of times like women
won't trust a man's judgment unless he
makes over a certain amount of money and
because a lot of times I ask the
question like would you quit your job if
your man told you to and like how much
money would he have to make for him to
do that and most of the time it's like
top five top ten percent of income but
like its submission is trusting a man's
judgment but average men can't get to
mission anymore
because women are fighting over five
percent of the dating Market ten percent
that's why women say men are trash toxic
acts like if you have an ex that cheated
he was probably top 20 of men most men
don't get sex like that hey as always
when you got like really bang bang
average got out of here that will come
out and they'll say yeah like I've never
cheated I've never stepped out I've
never done this but like you don't have
the option to
so like it's different when you've got
like the one percent of guys with all
the options in the world there's more
credit to those guys for actually
staying faithful because it's a lot more
difficult than the guy that you've had
that's like
it's like it's a way that men can offer
long-term term security to women as
they'll like say I'm not like these guys
those guys are bad and so it's like a
mating strategy sorry go ahead yeah now
I was saying I just think when it comes
to the cheating thing I I just think men
are built differently to women no matter
how we try to go around it how I might
feel when I see somebody that I think is
attractive I wouldn't go and do it
because
I'm a woman and I'm not made in that way
men can are stimulated in a different
way and they're going for what they want
so I thought the cheating thing's very
what's my saying men will have sex with
a whole animal she it is honestly not
the worst thing I can have it in a
relationship especially when you learn
to be secure especially when you
understand the real concept of and I
don't like people throwing this whole
lawyer love exclusive you can a man can
be loyalty in terms of showing up for
you and you need him to in terms of
being committed so you can also do that
and still cheat like it doesn't it's
like I think
there's a lot of insecurity and
possessiveness that I think you were
speaking about earlier that is rooted to
some of these relationships that makes
women want to hold on to this this is
mine and it's like he can be there for
you and give you everything that you
wanted make your list create your menu
that man can give you everything on that
menu and still cheated does not take
away from who you are like it just yeah
Andrew Tate said it was very interesting
agitate said women don't understand what
loyalty is because they think that a man
being loyal to them is never cheating
right but a man he used a scenario of
someone who likes apples if a man always
eats apples doesn't mean he's low to
Apples the man that's loyal to Apples
eats apples all the time and then eats a
strawberry but always comes back to
Apples he eats a banana but always comes
back to Apples and that is what loyalty
is loyalty means if if there's no if
there's no alternative I have no choice
but to be loyal to you and loyalty to a
man the way men see it is like but I'm
always coming back to you that means I'm
look I don't care about these other it's
just something that was kind of throw
away
but if I'm always coming back to you
that's what loyalty is I have a question
um for you Sarah actually both both of
you too
um
when do you think a man becomes disloyal
so if he if so if he okay if he he's
sleeping with other girls that doesn't
automatically mean he's disloyal is he
disloyal if like because don't you think
guys on some level ever developed
feelings for the side chick I've heard
stories where like side chicks get
written into the wills that like stuff
like that yeah yeah yeah so so when does
it become disloyal when he like you said
like when he takes his finances and his
time
and gives as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible